(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Line up the top
seven US carriers by size
and this is how it looks today.
But JetBlue's $3.8 billion
deal to buy Spirit Airlines
last month would change this picture.
The tie-up would see
Spirit folded into JetBlue
moving JetBlue one rung
up the ladder past Alaska.
- You know, the word they've
used is turbochargers
and that's probably right that, you know,
if they're able to get this deal done,
it really puts them
in a different class really quickly.
- [Narrator] But the so-called Big Four,
American, United, Delta and Southwest,
would maintain their places.
- If you look at what this is
it's really an acquisition about assets.
It's about JetBlue acquiring
Spirit for aircraft
and for the crew members, who
will operate those aircraft.
- [Narrator] The question is
can a bigger JetBlue compete and how?
Let's take a look at a few key metrics
to see where the company stands now,
where it will be if the deal goes through,
and if there could be a Big Five?
First, pilots.
Anyone who's been to an airport recently
knows that travel is rough right now.
One of the challenges
airlines have started
to grapple with this summer,
there aren't enough pilots.
Globally, demand for pilots is projected
to exceed supply by 2024.
But in North America, it's already here
and airlines are scrambling to both hire
and retain employees.
- You've seen carriers
like Spirit, Frontier,
Allegiant, JetBlue lose
pilots who's choosing to go
to United, American, Delta, Southwest.
And so this is really a way
for JetBlue to basically
acquire a cadre of pilots
to really fuel that growth.
- [Narrator] By adding
Spirit, JetBlue would jump
from having around 3,800
pilots to nearly 6,600.
That's still about half of Delta's
industry-leading 13,180 pilots.
- Having more pilots it just
gives them a lot more depth.
And so when they go into a new market,
they can offer multiple flights a day
instead of maybe just one, or they can go
into more new markets,
where they're not already present.
And you know that just
makes them potentially
more meaningful competitor.
- [Narrator] JetBlue would also benefit
from the type of pilots the deal brings.
JetBlue and Spirit, both
fly mostly Airbus aircraft.
- To have pilots who
are already a type rated
and qualified to fly an Airbus A320
or an A321 simplifies things
and really reduces cost for a JetBlue.
- [Narrator] Next up fleet.
Without its deal for Spirit,
JetBlue has a total of 282 jets
in its fleet putting it
well behind the Big Four.
- Getting planes it's just
difficult for airlines right now.
There's delays in deliveries,
manufacturing delays.
So just the idea of just quickly acquiring
a couple hundred planes was
very enticing for JetBlue.
- So acquiring Spirit's all Airbus fleet
would give JetBlue a total
of 458 planes JetBlue says,
with some 300 more on order.
- That would take it many years,
I think they've said eight
years, to sort of get
to that size that they
need to get organically.
So they kind of looked around and deciding
really the best way to
kind of jump to a size
that can even begin to compete
with these bigger airlines
is through an acquisition.
- [Narrator] These planes
won't fly as is though.
Spirit's yellow will be painted over
and JetBlue has said
it would take seats off
Spirit's packed planes
to bring them in line
with JetBlue's roomier model,
but even taking seats away,
this deal would bring JetBlue
thousands more seats total.
So let's talk about seats.
To see how the airline stacks up,
it's best to look at a metric
known as available seat miles.
This metric is calculated by multiplying
the number of seats
available on a given flight
by the number of miles
that plane will travel.
- The more ASMs you have,
the more capacity you have.
So it's a great metric to show the size
from a capacity standpoint of an airline.
- [Narrator] In 2021,
JetBlue had 54 billion
available seat miles.
Combining with Spirit's 40 billion
would edge the airline closer
to fourth place Southwest,
then sixth place, Alaska.
But even with Spirit, JetBlue's slice
of overall seat capacity will sit at 8%.
Analysts say to grow that,
JetBlue will need to expand its reach.
- I think what really
is needed for JetBlue
to get its share closer
to that of Southwest,
United, Delta, and America is to set up
some sort of a focus
city with material size
in the middle of the country.
- [Narrator] And lastly destinations.
Currently, JetBlue flies
to 98 destinations.
Spirit flies to 90.
The combined airline
wouldn't fly to 188 however.
That number is more like
127, according to JetBlue.
- Often in airline mergers
in the past, you know
regulators say, well,
this is where you overlap.
We need you to cut
certain gates at airports
or need you to divest
some assets in order to,
so there's not so much overlap.
If the deal is allowed to go forward
there will likely be
some pruning at least.
- 127 destinations would move
JetBlue just above Southwest,
which currently flies to 121 locations.
The other three would all have more
than double JetBlue's destinations.
(plane whooshing)
The deal would make Fort Lauderdale
JetBlue's busiest airport
according to a Cirium analysis.
The combined airline would then surpass
Southwest and Delta to become
Florida's second busiest
carrier by seats after American.
- Florida has been, especially
the last couple of years
just one of the busiest
places in the country to fly.
It is important to airlines
to have a meaningful presence there
and growing there can be
really advantageous for them.
- [Narrator] JetBlue says
it's larger presence in cities
like Ford Lauderdale, would
drive down prices for flyers.
However, JetBlue would be
taking an ultra low cost carrier
out of the equation.
And some argue that less
competition could end up
raising prices for all.
Proving that competition
and low prices will remain
after the deal will be key
to getting regulators to bless the merger.
- JetBlue has argued
that the government has
allowed the creation
of four really big airlines
that dominate the market
by allowing all of these mergers.
And that the only way to
address that situation
is to allow another
carrier to kind of bulk up
and get big enough to challenge
those four big airlines.
- [Narrator] Spirit and
former suitor Frontier,
had previously argued
that regulators would almost
certainly prevent a merger
between Spirit and JetBlue
and that the review
process could hobble spirit
for up to two years.
JetBlue has said that any deal,
including the failed combination
between Spirit and Frontier
would face similar levels
of pushback from regulators.
JetBlue expects the
deal to receive approval
and be finalized by the first half of 2024
followed by a four to five
year integration process.
And analysts say an even longer time
before it might truly
challenge the Big Four.
- It won't be five years from now.
Won't be 10 years from
now, but I think what this
does is create a combined
airline that becomes competitive
with those Big Four
and really makes the future JetBlue
relevant in the industry.
(gentle music)